das ist der vorwurf der diese woche
wieder gemacht wird von einigen
prominenten in einem aufruf in der zeit
dass diese waffenlieferungen diesen
krieg unnötig wie sie schreiben wie zb
jakob augstein frage schreibt unnötig
verlängert hätten man kämpft dann nicht
mehr für eine sinnvolle sache sagt er
und dieser aufruf der sagt der mensch
waffenstillstand um jeden preis wir
machen das nur immer länger und immer
länger haben diese promis recht sie
nennen sich ja nicht promis nennen
sicher intellektuelle das ist ja viel
schlimmer dass er augstein eine solche
bemerkung macht er wisse nicht wofür die
ukraine kämpft finde ich erschüttern man
kann immer dinge unterschiedlich sehen
musste auch sachlich darüber diskutieren
aber einem land was überfallen wurde wo
es um die integrität der grenzen gibt
übrigens ist die uno sieht 47 gegründet
worden damit so etwas eben nicht mehr
passiert werte basierte politik wo
menschen umgebracht werden wo
kinderkrankenhäuser bombardiert werden
und all die dramatischen dinge von denen
wir wissen wer das nicht versteht oder
dass sich da die ukraine wert da kann
ich nur sagen da sollte man mit dem
intellekt doch vielleicht noch mal neu
anfangen
faßbender teilen sie das frau strack
zimmermann hat zwar getwittert das wirkt
wie auch sie wie satire wenn ich sie da
richtig zitiere teilen sie das so der
text der text dieses brief ist wirkt auf
mich jetzt nicht wie satie und auch
nicht wieso intellektuell ich verstehe
den aufstand auch nicht in dem text
dieses briefes als jemand der nicht
begreift worum es hier eigentlich geht
wenn man muss vorausschicken dass die
klare verlangst des westens die
eindeutige reaktion der ukraine eine
völlig notwendige folge einer
regelverletzung war die beispiellos war
in den vergangenen 30 jahren in dem was
wir seit dem kalten krieg erlebt haben
das große problem ist dass wir nachdem
diese verlangt bei aufgestellt hat
nachdem russland seine taktik jahr 23
mal auf seine kriegsziele geändert hat
nachdem wir jetzt in einen
stellungskrieg hineinlaufen die große
frage ist jetzt ob wir einfach auf der
gewählten linie waffen waffen waffen
liefern ja weiter marschieren wie lange
mit welchem ziel im hintergrund hinter
kommen oder ob wir nicht und da glaube
ich gibt dieser brief schon einiges her
der erst gab es schon einen ersten brief
der kanton wallis war
völlig richtig dass das war viel zu früh
das war bevor er letzten endes auch
genügend tatsachen sowohl politisch als
auch auf dem schlachtfeld getroffen
worden heute haben wir mehr tatsachen
heute können wir klarer absehen und ich
halte es die zeitpunkt wo jetzt der
brief kommt ich gehöre bei weitem nicht
zu den unterzeichnern also ich bin ja
auch kein promi aber der zeitpunkt
gefällt gefällt mir insofern besser als
dass wir jetzt absehen wir haben
möglicherweise die chance und lange denn
war mit waffen zu tun und gelernt habe
war fassbender frau streckt zimmermann
sagt das ist satire sie nimmt das im
grunde nicht ernst
der intellektuelle habe ich habe das
wort sagt ihre in einem anderen kontext
genutzt weil verstehen der von der
stetig sagt ihr parteifreund ja nein
also ich muss schon sagen es sind
ernsthaft der menschen auch kluge
menschen die sich ernsthafte sorgen
machen und das muss man ernst nehmen
weil sie befürchten dass diese situation
die wir haben eskalieren kann dass es
egal wo auch noch mehr opfer fordert und
darüber wollen sie richard david precht
auch 100 ingenieure an genauer und
darüber zu reden gibt es auch einen
anderen weg oder vielleicht auch kein
sowohl kein entweder oder sondern ein
sowohl als auch ich sage auch ich finde
es richtig was zu liefern damit die
ukraine sich verteidigen kann ich
erwarte aber immer parallel auch
diplomatische bemühungen und ich bin
kein träumer ich weiß dass man mit putin
nicht reden kann und ich würde dem nie
trauen wenn er irgendwas unterschreibt
aber gibt es andere wege diplomatische
wege um das dieses diese sorge auch
aufzugreifen und tatsächlich um auch
möglichst schnell in einen zustand zu
kommen wurde nicht nur die waffen
sprechen qimonda ist eine rauschhafte
dass es einen anderen weg gibt das ist
die spd regierungsfraktion das ist
spd-außenpolitiker müller das ist der
ralf stegner der ja auch ein gewaltiges
wort dort in der spd-fraktion zu sagen
hat die stützen diesen aufruf an die der
aufruf sagt eben waffenstillstand jetzt
hier und das sind alle die das land den
frieden zu schaffen also ich hätte es ja
verstehen dass man nach zufrieden ist
und dass man sagt wir wollen möglichst
schnell in frieden haben durch meine
kritik an diesen ersten brief und an den
zweiten ist es ist völlig konträr ich
mal der es gibt versuche wir haben ja
immer wie die telefonate erlebt von
makro mit putin inzwischen komme sondern
mitschnitt veröffentlicht oder zeigt
dass dieses telefonat völlig sind was
war und ich denke mal das andere wird
aussagen es ist vielleicht dann sinnvoll
wenn herr man sich mal mut fasst und
sage lieber wladimir hat den krieg ist
im eimer du hast nicht das geschafft
dass du dir erreicht hast und im grunde
können bitte jetzt helfen rauszukommen
also wir müssen mit breiter brust
auftreten da nicht ängstlich hier
reichlich denn mit breiter brust dann
immer ganz klar sagen dieser krieg wo
ein strategischer fehlschlag russlands
russland hat sich völlig verausgabt in
diesem krieg also von den 200.000 man
die dort einmarschiert sind sind heute
vielleicht noch
60 70.000 es hoch kommt sind noch
einsatzbereit der rest ist entweder tod
verwundet oder gefangen genommen und das
ist eine verdammt große zahl also
russland hat seine innovationsfähigkeit
weitgehend verloren ist macht nur krieg
in diesem kleinen bereich in der größe
eines eines deutschen landkreis ist aber
wollen sich eine stadt auch da hinten
nächsten immer aus ja gut dass also
innerhalb von zehn wochen haben sie
ungefähr 200 quadratkilometer erobert
gleichzeitig haben die ukraine im süden
und im norden ungefähr die gleiche menge
erobert nur das wird nicht so mit würdig
so zu registriert also ich sag mal man
muss da man muss das mal ganz ganz
nüchtern sehen sowohl die russin als
auch die ukraine sind militärisch fast
am ende das ist vielleicht eine chance
aber ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich eine
chance zu sagen für ihre fraktionen aber
und so steht es in dem aufruf auch von
eben diesen prominenten von diesen
selbsternannten intellektuell dass man
dass man diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
michael obus tischen wird erstmal schon
dieses sogenannte
da werden leute diffamiert die sich
sorgen machen sie sind nicht die
einzigen sind nicht nur diese 40 oder 50
leute sondern wenn man sich die umfragen
anguckt viele menschen in unserem land
machen sich sorgen aber wieso kriegt was
ich sehe und das kann man auch ernst
nehmen und deswegen diskussion geraten
gerade auch von einem experten da ist da
hat sich was verändert in den letzten
wochen putin hat seine ziele nicht
erreicht die ukraine sind sehr stark und
da ist vielleicht auch mal eine chance
wo man sagen kann beide seiten sind in
einer situation wo es nöten aber als
kabarettistische anhebe 7 in dem brief
steht drin in dem aufruf steht drin dass
das unrealistisch ist so hatte ich sie
auch gerade verstanden erfasst man
derzeit professor krause das ist
realistisch die russische armee zu
besiegen die ist schon ganz schön runter
gekommen was sagen sie
also was ist denn dann das ziel also es
wird solange waffen geliefert und das
wird so lange gekämpft bis die russische
armee besiegt ist bisher aus der ukraine
erst mal durch schon mal wieder was ganz
anderes wir schon was ganz anderes dass
sie aus der ukraine raus ist es ganz
anders als russland besiegen ist etwas
völlig an was hast du noch nie hat
gefordert dass russland besiegt werden
muss ich kann mir die russische armee
besiegt ist was völlig hatte das gesetz
so und darüber muss man auch schon mal
reden was ist das ziel und ich staune
darüber wie wir jetzt anfangen mal
wieder die ziele zu interpretieren
eigentlich interpretiert nur die ukraine
nur die haben das recht zu sagen wie
weit es gehen soll und wie weit es auch
nicht mehr wir müssen ja wissen wollen
was ihr dabei und also da sowas kauft ja
wer ist dann die ukraine in ihrem kampf
zu unterstützen wenn sie ihn so auch
weiter für heer bei hohen ausgaben und
bei ständigen waffenlieferungen und
einer krassen inflation in deutschland
würde ich schon erwarten dass die
regierungsfraktion hier sagen was ist
eigentlich unser ziel in diesem konflikt
in diesem krieg können sie verlieren
doch was ist dass ihr uns definieren
muss es ja mal einordnen russland hat
die ukraine überfallen und ermordet wie
eine
stichprobe das ist unzweifelhaft
russland hat die integrität der grenzen
der ukraine damit über bord geworfen das
heißt aus meiner sicht ist das ziel das
die russische armee sich aus den
gebieten in denen sie sich jetzt
völkerrechtswidrig auffällt zurückzieht
einschließlich gekommen wir sind jetzt
fertig aber folge sind jetzt im moment
wir sind jetzt februar wenn du was war
21 das heißt ich würde so weit gehen zu
sagen das ist der erste schritt hörst du
das nicht im moment aber lassen sie mich
den gedanken zu ende führen das ist das
ziel dass dieser überfall entsprechend
dass die das rote rosen zurückzieht das
ist von ganz entfernt ich bin bei ihnen
letztlich hat es nur die ukraine zu
entscheiden fakt ist aber auch das ist
nie und nimmer und deswegen bin ich da
auch so hartleibig nicht weil ich das so
toll finde waffen zu liefern wirklich
nicht wird es mit wladimir putin auf
diplomatische art und weise die immer
diese versuche müssen immer stattfinden
genau darauf zurück in seine hat vor
einem jahr noch ein aufsatz geschrieben
ist gerade die sprecherin von
außenminister lavrov gesagt in zwei
jahren ist die ganze ukraine
verschwunden das ziel bleibt mir putins
ist dass die ukraine komplett von der
landkarte verschwindet und deswegen
glaube ich nicht weil ich das schön
finde dass dieser konflikt letztlich nur
militärisch gelöst werden kann noch eine
sache weil ja menschen angst muss man
sehr hellhörig sein habe ich großes
verständnis wenn aber menschen die
intellektuell sich damit beschäftigt
haben oder her auch stein explizit sagt
dass er es nicht verstehen könne den
sinn nicht versteht warum die ukraine
sich werth sorry das haut wirklich dem
fass den boden aus da nützt auch auf das
hat auch nichts mehr mit erklärung zu
tun das ist eine ignoranz einem volk
gegenüber wo wir über sechs millionen
dass die fähre meinung ja noch ganz
gefährlichen die sogar sehr gefährlich